another breaking story this morning the
average cost of a full tank of petrol
for a typical 55 liter family car has
now exceeded a hundred pounds for the
first time this is figures from the data
firm experian catalyst we're getting a
response also from uh the rac
they say it is a truly dark day today
for drivers with petrol now crossing the
thoroughly depressing threshold of a
hundred pounds a tank it's gone up to a
hundred pounds and 27 pence uh a
complete diesel fill up now at 103
pounds and 43 pence uh let's bring back
skies and here in ag in a petrol station
uh for us in london today and ashley
motorists don't need to be told how
expensive petrol is i think all of us
are are driving past looking at the
numbers and thinking maybe the next
garage will have it cheaper maybe the
next carriage will have it cheaper then
you realize that none of them have a
cheaper do they
no that's right jane you used to be
quite savvy as a motorist or lots of
people would be quite savvy and that you
might pick and choose where you went to
fill up but we are fast running out of
affordable options and the rac
spokesperson there as you quoted has
said that this is a truly dark day the
fact that we have reached a hundred
pounds to fill up a tank of petrol on
average family sized car in the uk
is quite stark and this is a kind of
unprecedented landmark that we've
reached within a week within a matter of
days on monday we were talking about the
fact that prices for petrol were 178 p
per liter now it's
182.31 for a litre of unleaded and 188
for diesel and that equates to as we've
as we've heard now
over 100 pounds for filling up your
petrol car and over still even more so
for your diesel car this is a price
point that a lot of people are going to
have a hard time trying to come to terms
with already this morning we've spoken
to a number of motorists who have called
it already difficult unsustainable one
person saying that they're going to have
to ditch their car at home now and just
rely on public transport and and getting
around by bike and a lot of people
saying that even when it comes to short
errands short journeys people are simply
not able to
afford to
bank on using their car as much as as
they possibly can this comes at a time
of course where other parts of cost of
living crisis are starting to to bite
when you think about bills going up and
food and drink and now to even get
around things are becoming more
difficult yes in march the government
did bring in this cut to the fuel duty
by five pence but the concern is as
we've heard this morning from the
leveling up secretary michael gove there
are concerns that that
discount isn't being translated by
retailers onto the forecourts and and is
affecting the custom consumers in a
positive way it's meant to be saving
consumers
100 pounds on average a year but if
they're not getting that 5p discount
here on the four courts then it's not
going to really make much of a
difference to that final bill but lots
of people here already affected and in
the next few days the price behind me it
currently sits at 197 for unleaded with
this news now it's likely to climb even
further
thanks very much
well uh let's get more on this and the
latest business news now from the heart
of the city is there any good news
hello jane well i mean inflation is not
just a uk phenomenon it may feel like
that here that uh we're the only ones
grappling with the cost of living crisis
but inflation is endemic worldwide right
now and if i tell you this it's quite an
amazing statistic so far this year there
have been 141 individual interest rate
rises around the world obviously here in
the uk from the bank of england in the
united states from the federal reserve
but central banks right around the world
have been raising interest rates we had
interest rate rises in both india and
australia earlier this week the
canadians have moved fairly recently
poland israel south africa the list just
goes on and on but there is one place
which has been very very conspicuously
not raising interest rates and that is
the eurozone well today we get a meeting
from the european central bank and
whilst they're not expected to raise
interest rates today they are expected
to signal that a rate rise is coming now
interest rates in the eurozone have been
at minus half of one percent since
september 2019 they've had negative
rates for many many years we're
expecting today from the ecb a signal
that that is going to come to an end in
the very near future and potentially by
the third quarter of this year they may
even be out of negative interest rates
altogether we're also expecting by the
way an end to the ecb's quantitative
easing uh emergency asset purchases put
in place during the pandemic they have
bought 1.7 trillion euros worth of
government and corporate bonds we're
expecting that to come to an end today